we would like to welcome all our branch
members fellow governors as well as
academy members and other branches to
view our virtual bake off i would love
for you to meet
your brother
uh lavell uh princess tenaci and
princess uma this is your bastard
brother and this is my eldest daughter
acid brother they know please talk about
the world of zamunda where you showcased
african culture in your hair styling
which i thought was just impeccable i
mean this was a amazing platform for us
to exemplify textured hair that look on
wesley it's an east african style it was
very important for us to bring this
african element to this fantasy african
country and he was the person to do it
creating those peaks with the valley and
the crescent shapes was so important for
us
[Music]
how much involvement did emma stone have
it in her books also just talk a little
bit about the stencil makeup that the
future which i love when i saw that i'm
like that's so awesome she kind of just
lets me run with things and i
and every time i thought
i kind of want to do this she just let
me she just let me do it and the future
makeup came from i had the sex pistols
album never mind the bollocks was off on
my mood boards i think i just kept
seeing it by osmosis it sort of kept
going in that scene particular all it
said is that she turns up on a motorbike
and crashes the baroness party and the
next scene the next day the headline
says is cruella the future
and i thought how can i
be literal about this can't be any more
literal than write it across her face
so it was just this kind of black
like a tire mark across her face
and then the font is the same font as
the sex pistols album so um
and then it was just kind of placing it
on so that we could also we could
actually see the future
the last of our ships have left rockets
it's done
very good
uncle how can we let this happen
how can the emperor
take
everything we've built and give it to
that duke
how
don't be too sure it's an act of love
when is a gift not a gift
the artist's voice is rising
the emperor is a jealous man
a dangerous
jealous man
could you please share with us specifics
that you oversaw and the onset
application for the baron character
everybody had to sort of do everything
even if you normally don't do it you had
to help out because it was a massive
character to do foam work and you had to
do seaming and i repainted and everybody
just sort of had to help out when we
started shooting we had some problem
with the paint
it was a bit tricky to blend that into
the silicone pieces that he had in his
entire face because the nose and the
upper lip wasn't covered with
prosthetics and he had a cooling tent
where we put him in between when he was
shooting you had to adjust the makeup
all the time because it was just so much
makeup and he was so big so you had to
start working on him all day long
but it was fun but it was also
a big task
[Music]
so would you share with us how you began
the process of figuring out all the
stages for each of the characters and
would you go through their different
stories i think on a project like this
research is key so i watched a lot of
the old footage christian broadcast
network ptl nightline interviews they
had done together and separately larry
king so the beauty element was super
important to me on all our characters
but particularly with tammy face so it
meant working very closely with
prosthetics we tested a few different
looks with jessica early on and really
kind of landed on what i call the
hallmark elements and then those sort of
main elements carried and sort of
dictated how we would go throughout the
timelines and aging her i think that
subtle approach really
allowed jessica the freedom and andrew
the freedom to perform without feeling
like they were encased in prosthetics
gucci is my name too
you
abused the gucci name no no no
start to the train
no i didn't i swear i didn't okay it's
my name it's not even your real name
okay let's talk a little bit about what
you went through working with euron and
jared in determining his look for his
hair the creation of the wigs and how
you went about showing the transition of
time that occurs in the course of
filming we looked at reference photos
and we could see that paolo had a lot of
different styles he had shorter he had
long hair ponytail he had darker hair
and he went to gray white dish but we
found one picture that we liked he had
really nice bushy side bird shoulder
length hair with a bit of curls and a
mustache and we started to work from
that really the first time i met jared
was the day before shooting and realized
that he had
super long hair
and thick hair and all of that was
needed to be hidden underneath the
bald cap and prosthetics without
creating a giant head of course because
that would have looked silly and then i
realized that the wig i had made was too
small so i did the neck piece to make it
all fit together a bit crazy but quite
fun also
we would like to congratulate and thank
the artists you have met today for their
work that has delighted and transported
us to the world of storytelling thank
you and we'll see you guys at the oscars
you